what Ted really was made by a major
technological disruption it happened
about 10 years ago you know the price of
bandwidth plummeted back in 2004 the
cost of sending up a lecture from person
a two-person be on the other side of the
world was effectively two dollars just
for one one piece of communication you'd
have to copy it onto a DVD mail it
across the world and then they'd dead
view it and then Internet bandwidth
plummeted in cost and suddenly it was
possible to do this thing called online
video and so within literally not much
more than a year the the real world cost
of sharing 15 minutes of information
information plummeted from a couple
dollars to about a penny or two now that
was a surface punishing shift because it
suddenly meant that a sponsor could
cover that cost if need be effectively
the cost of sending an idea was free and
so we you know tried an experiment to
put a few talks up online to our
astonishment they went viral and
suddenly Ted turned on its head and
instead of being a once-a-year
conference in California it became this
you know online idea of ideas worth
spreading the interesting thing about
technology is that it's a it's a mixture
of surprises and predictability I mean
the most famous piece of predictability
is something like Moore's law where over
many years you see a trend that almost
becomes a self-fulfilling thing where an
entire industry acts as if Moore's Law
were true and thereby in a sense makes
it come true because that creates the
market to justify the investment in ever
more powerful computer chips etc and so
there are definite trends that you can
look at it's been obvious for a while
that the internet was changing
everything and there's a road map out
there right now that is actually an
amazing road map and possibly under
appreciated that the internet is
spreading to every corner of the planet
and will be low cost high bandwidth
everywhere companies like Facebook and
Google are investing billions of dollars
to make sure that this is so and that's
a complete game changer that means for
the first time in history not 1 billion
but seven billion people plus will be
interconnected what does that mean who
knows but it's it's it's possible to
dream about that future because the
technical odd the technological
landscape is set out and it's it's clear
and so that's certainly something that
we're thinking about it changes our
strategy what is a TED talk of the
future what would you say if you could
have 18 minutes to talk to the girl in
the village the boy and the slum we
don't know the answers to those
questions but we sure as hell need to
figure them out